the classical music was as is always the
case in middle class european jewish
homes it was a requirement everybody saw
played an instrument my mother was an
amateur pianist and the interesting part
was that she was a physician a very
distinguished physician and she lost her
hearing through a very strange disease
where she lost hearing on both sides z
the Jonathan Swift had called Meniere's
and it destroys the inner ear so you
lose not only volume but pitch and when
I was a little boy I have no real memory
of my mother ever hearing so she lost
her hearing gradually in fits and starts
and the thing that was most tragic it
seemed to me as a child was that she was
no longer able to play so I think that
was a kind of psychological motivator
for me to study music so they were very
encouraging and I started out in the
piano then switch to the violin
well we started out in sort of a varies
of ignorant context as to say my parents
knowing nobody through you know some
recommendations through other Emma
Grey's we ended up with an émigré piano
teacher and then I ended up with a
violin teacher again through
recommendations and finally I was lucky
when I was an adolescent on my
grandparents lived in Mexico City and so
I spent the summers there and there was
an émigré german austrian violin teacher
herbert Furley who actually set me
straight and through him I was in
recommended to my major teacher Roman
Totenberg very distinguished violinist
was alive today at 99 Oh fantastic
violence and fantastic teacher so I
started with him for seven years but
then during my late adolescence already
thought I want to be either a composer
conductor I tried my hand at composing
and I didn't write music that I found
memorable myself I was more interesting
other people's music so I then got
interested in doing conducting and then
rise in college I began to study and do
conducting